j'ai dans mon dernier discours au
parlement européen j'ai commandé
monsieur michel barnier pour son
sang-froid
donc je vous demande tous à garder votre
sang froid je pense que le président
macron a tout à fait raison de rester
très ferme pour le droit des citoyens et
citoyennes en irlande du nord est les
citoyens européens en ayant en irlande
du nord et européens ici en écosse où je
vous le rappelle ont voté pour rester
dans l'union européenne
l'ecosse a voté à 70 % pour rester dans
l'union européenne donc nous sommes des
nations qui se sent très européenne
nous connaissons nos droits et nous
voulons nous voulons les conserver
donc s'il vous plaît pensez à nous
penser à bellaing du nord gardez votre
sang froid rester ferme et penser que
l'ecosse peut revenir très rapidement au
sein de l'union européenne comme une
écosse indépendante et ça sera peut-être
la première nation de la grande bretagne
qui reviennent dans l'union européenne
et ça c'est un avenir qu'il faut
commencer à construire aujourd'hui
[Musique]